[Music]
in prolonged teen news submitted by
fashion herded scientists have now
increased the age of adulthood from 19
to 24 I agree when I was passed my teens
I still felt like a child and I still
feel like a child today because when you
hear stories of grandpa and grandma and
all that stuff it's like they were
already back grandpa and grandma 18
years old yeah so crazy living alone and
then raising eight children and like
back then OSU seen the opposite yeah
when they're 18 yeah so now this I'm
saying 24 is and you cut off we had 24
is then like we're adulthood should be
considered as when that begins I agree
with the Spartans I think 30 is when
adulthood begins I agree with that one
too because the Spartans believe like
you're a man man when you're 30 years
old was it the same for women or women
were like you don't count I think when
women were ready to give birth they were
women so that means they're mature women
at like 14 or 15 or something but some
have it earlier though I just took it
god damn it oh my god damn and now we
have to like give birth and do all some
[ __ ] childbirth I don't feel like you
can be a man if you don't have any life
experience so I agree with like the
later on it is I think it's actually
better well we're here so what they're
talking about here there's like a lot of
factors that fall into why they they're
pushing the adulthood age up to 24
because for starters they're saying that
puberty now is beginning earlier so back
of the day would be like around the age
of 14 13 that's unlike puberty we'll
start that your body starts changing but
now because of the fact that like the
food industry and like all the hormones
or the hormones that they're putting in
now a lot of kids are starting puberty
at the age of 10 Wow are they basing
this off of regular people or Mexican
people this their [ __ ] Belov's you is
that Ted they [ __ ] out of my hormones
yeah no not you
my mustache coming right now Micah has a
mustache I remember I remember there's
this dude in fifth grader like a full on
beer and I'm like what the huh
it was I pal all the way down here I I
had a friend that started her period
when she was in the second grade I was
she of Hispanic no sir
Filipino no what was she yeah Japanese
although there the horniest yeah I
believe it we're the hairiest in the
horny you know she likes develop faster
she was telling me she told a teacher
and like she just said it out loud
and it's usually Koshi you shouldn't say
it out loud and she was like why my
pussy's bleeding like she couldn't
separate the two because it was like it
didn't seem like a big deal to her but
that the teacher was making it a bigger
deal on this she the teacher a jazz
teacher
she I don't think it shamed her but it
was just more of like I don't understand
why I trippin yeah just help me [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
cuz period talk isn't shameful in our
family so maybe it's not in mine either
that's good
I was embarrassed in my [ __ ] yes I was I
my knees would just be like oh my period
was so out of control yesterday I
couldn't go out all the guys are like oh
damn well these you're comfortable with
you I guess you cuz my mom was concerned
when I didn't get my period cuz like she
was like oh you need to see the doctor I
was like I think I'm fine what did you
have your peer when you're 20 I know I
think when I was like is that is that
like 15 I don't know cuz like in school
they said like 14 is probably the latest
and if you don't get it after 14 you
should probably see the doctor do really
I heard it was like after 15 or 16 maybe
you should do a talk yeah but my mom was
just concerned she's like you didn't get
it yeah it's like you're about to go to
high school I was like mom chill is
probably gonna come mom's always been
handy she'd been like I'm pregnant
that's why I get it
yes that's one reason and then another
reason is that they're saying that
weight before in the past they would say
that you know your brain stops
developing sus maturing by the age of 20
but then now they're saying like no a
lot of people like the brain still
continues to mature wave has 20 and then
there's even people that get their
wisdom teeth at the age of 25 like just
so your body is just prolonging the
whole like development I should all have
my wisdom teeth ramier every time I go
there they're like I can pull it up I
don't really need to it's like a
convertible like there was half the gum
as exposed and half the tip is exposed
no cuz I got mine pulled out it all was
around 25 that's when it started coming
out and [ __ ] hurting my I was getting
these flagged wisdom teeth headaches
Mel's like oh gotta become an employee
so I could get health insurance was
always just waiting till I became a full
employee so I could use their health
insurance at school I learned that um
the prefrontal cortex is the thing that
just makes you who you are as a person
nerd that's cute well I've learned
something we're talking si like I hate
science go ahead and they and they said
that your cognitive decisions based on
the studies they say that at the age of
23 you're already pretty much settled to
who you are now I was a dumbass no I
don't think so that's not that it's it's
harder to shape a person's cognitive
like thinking skills and like how they
solve problems and stuff like that
after 40 40 is when when it's kind of
like really set in stone not I don't
think it's 23 then maybe that study is
wrong yeah or bias or it could be
changing or obeah I progressively get
more negative as the years go by so I
think I'm always changing so another
reason why they're increasing the the
adulthood age is because a lot of people
are delaying life's milestones like
getting married having children so like
for example obviously yeah it's
happening all over the world in
developed countries yeah exactly so for
this particular conversation here
they're using the UK back in 2013 the
average age for a man to enter marriage
in the UK was 24 years old
but then now it's 30 2.5 years old and
for windows so it's like about 8 and 8
year increase oh damn I believe it I
believe that too because in middle
school and in high school just singing
oh yeah by the time I graduate college
you'll be like well be like 22 23 that's
another reason a lot of people are still
continuing their education yeah and then
I was like oh by 25 I'll probably be
finding somebody and like getting
married and probably 27 I'll probably
have kids and I'm like nowhere near any
that's what I was thinking - like a dumb
ass dude and now I'm scared but also
living in a big city you guys know the
cost of living is outrageous yeah it's
very different I'm pretty sure like in
places that are you know cheaper like
the Midwest maybe people are just
marrying earlier and they're having kids
and it's like oh [ __ ] you already have
two kids and we're the same age it's the
majority though what they're looking at
like the average it is a lot later yeah
that's true cuz it's not weird it's not
like oh you're way past your prime if I
see a single lady like in her 30s I
don't think Oh too late lady do you know
what I mean like it's like oh yeah I
even look like that
I mean I think you were mentioning it
that kids are losing their virginity
later now yeah yeah previous good I
think it depends on what group of kids
you're talking to though yeah especially
not other is starting puberty at ten oh
my dear God if they're starting puberty
at ten and Instagram has an unlimited
supply of spank bank materials dude just
wait till one day you pick up Isaac
boxers and they're extra still mom I've
been starching my boxers to get a crease
like come on now but why only in the
middle yo does his room smell yet he's
not a good kid now like must be like
it's our kid yeah as soon as he gets
home from school lets go take a shower
man thank you
his testosterone is building yeah it
started to rev up rum
boys even crack now and like before
reading this like once I saw this
article I'm like oh so it is true
because before reading this article I
kept seeing these like mini signs of him
like going towards the are you seeing
his like I mean if you tell by his teeth
when his teeth start falling out on the
hill ready starting yeah you're living
longer - its baby teeth are moving
what's his shoe size right now he's my
size he's a guy's he's a three I think
he could wear his shoes yeah he's gonna
be like a [ __ ] in like a year
yeah maybe less you know and then he's
throwing at his little peach fuzz I'm
like yeah I was born I've been getting
my peach residue so then when we become
grandpa's then people are gonna become
adults at 35 I know right do you think
they're gonna keep increasing it yeah so
this was just like an opinion piece
though I mean these are scientists over
having these opinions but then there's
this other expert this doctor saying
that you're stupid [ __ ] saying that she
doesn't agree with this because it risks
further infantilizing young people so
like just babying them a lot longer
which is true a lot of my dad's friends
all their kids are late 20s early 30s
and a lot of them still live at home
with their parents if I could live at
home with my parents I'd do it I don't
think I would mind if my kid lived at
home it's a failure to launch reason
though it's like it's not that they're
saving money it's not a functional
reason it's because they fail to launch
yeah yeah yeah I'd be big problem with
that I like cooking but it's a lot
better wouldn't just parents do it but
that stop because you know how to do it
so if my kid was like you and knew how
to do but just chose not to I'm like
cool like like this guy like he knows
how to do a lot of stuff but magically
doesn't know how to turn on the washer
the dryer but stop infect Aliza him and
give her some life stones you know give
you live songs know
yeah see mentalizing him
[Music]